macaques love to monkey around here in
southern India when a peddler leaves a
fruit cart unattended for just a single
moment these bonnet macaques pounce on
is like hungry ants at a company picnic
those of you with very young children
will recognize this kind of eating
behavior so many peanuts so little time
then bananas well naturally oranges
basically whatever isn't nailed down and
if they can cry it up it's not nailed
down what a macaque doesn't eat on the
spot it puts in doggy bags called
its cheek pouches which it uses while
foraging for more food now it's on to
the next meal the bowl on the cats with
their distinctively long tails aren't
afraid to raid homes in search of food
and just an all-around good time now
grapes are always good full of fruit
sugar for the energy they'll need to
wreak havoc like a bunch of seven year
olds at an out-of-control birthday party
just when you think it can't get any
worse
it gets worse
they've been so destructive that the
Forest Service relocates them from the
city to a faraway forest